herzlich willkommen an den
empfangsgeräten zu zdf heute live und
ihrem live stream zu aktuellen
ereignissen
und da ist heute das thema des tages das
erste tv-duell zwischen us präsident
donald trump und seinem demokratischen
herausforderer joe biden
diese tv duelle sind in den usa eine
langjährige große tradition 3 gibt's da
immer und normalerweise ist das auch
schon so dass das hier diskutiert wird
mit hitzigen vorwürfen hin und her
aber dieses mal ist es dann doch noch
etwas vielleicht etwas besonderes
gewesen denn donald trump als
us-präsident ist ja bekannt für seine
verbalen angriffe in alle richtungen und
auch dafür dass er mit traditionellen
regeln und auch abkommen gerne mal
bricht sein herausforderer joe biden ist
er ein moderater politiker schon lange
auch mit viel erfahrung war
vizepräsident unter barack obama und da
wurde natürlich jetzt drauf geguckt wie
wird dieses pärchen sich duellieren auf
dem diskussions boden
die haben sich muss man jetzt schon
vorweg sagen fast so eine art verbale
prügelei geliefert wir haben mal ein
paar sequenzen zusammengeschnitten
er musste moderator chris wallace fox
news anchor gleich dazwischen gehen und
sagen ja ihr unterbricht verständlich
also mache ich das auch wir rechnen
reden darüber über dieses erste tv duell
mit unserem korrespondenten mrt wissen
der ist in seinem hotelzimmer hat dort
das tv-duell verfolgt guten morgen emma
das dauert ein bisschen die leitung das
hört ihre fragen die kommentare zu dem
thema bitte immer gern in die
kommentarspalten
wir gucken was wir dazu sagen können und
wir gucken welche fragen beantworten
können aber die erste große frage ist
natürlich gewesen was war das jetzt für
ein tv duell wie der kurze ausschnitt
gerade hat ja schon gezeigt so richtig
traditionell ging das ganze nicht
vonstatten oder
ja ich glaube das war so ziemlich das
unwürdige schauspiel was wir je bei
einer präsidentschafts debatte in den
letzten jahrzehnten hier in den usa
erlebt habe dass meine nicht nur ich
sondern dass man viele beobachter von
zeitungen aber auch von fernsehsendern
rundfunkstationen man es sich ja nicht
das hat man so noch nicht erlebt es hat
viel damit zu tun dass donald trump sich
offenbar entschieden hat seinem
kontrahenten gewissermaßen seinem
twitter-feed an den kopf zu werfen stück
für stück beleidigungen und
beschimpfungen aber eben auch viele
behauptungen teilweise auch
falschbehauptungen und lügen joe biden
hat zunächst mal versucht dem
auszuweichen und nicht unmittelbar
darauf einzugehen aber er hat das nicht
lange durchgehalten weil er eben immer
und immer wieder bei seinen antworten
unterbrochen worden ist und er hat sich
dann in einigen punkten auf das gleiche
niveau hin abgegeben kann man sagen also
auch er hat schimpfwörter geäußert hat
der präsidentin einen clown genannt und
unterm strich ist so ein bisschen das
was inhaltlich auch vorhanden war in der
debatte
trotzdem am ende in diesem jahr
unwürdigen stil untergegangen ich kann
jetzt schon aus den kommentaren melden
hier ist auch viel beschwerde über das
diskussions niveau zu sehen
ich schau mal hier zum beispiel thomas
lipke schreibt auf facebook man bekommt
angst egal wer gewinnt eine katastrophe
für die usa wenn müller meint hochgradig
asoziales verhalten war dass jörg
niederschreibt bostelmann qualified die
paper wir wollen trotzdem versuchen die
auseinander zu nehmen denn ganz
interessant war dass sich fox news
moderator chris wallace mehrere
themenblöcke vorgenommen hat sechs stück
was an der zahl die korona pandemie
natürlich großes thema dann die
besetzung des supreme courts nach dem
tod von ruth bader ginsburg rassismus im
land die proteste dagegen die wirtschaft
und die wahl dann selbst wir haben nicht
zeit für alle aber ein paar gucken uns
mal an wir gehen mal los mit kuchen ein
großes thema in den usa 205.000 tote
bislang und sieht nicht so aus als ob
die pandemie dort zum einem halb gehalt
kommen würde
die lösung der pandemie da liegen ja
beide doch sehr weit auseinander
ja der präsident sagt im grunde genommen
dass es eigentlich kein großes problem
mehr gibt jetzt kommt der impfstoff
behauptete er in wenigen wochen und dann
ist die sache erledigt ihm geht es vor
allen dingen darum dass die wirtschaft
wieder auf die beine kommt und joe biden
sagte eben dagegen das funktioniert
nicht so lange man dass corinna virus
nicht besiegt hat und die eigenen
berater zumindest die wissenschaftlichen
berater des präsidenten so joe biden
würden ja selber sagen dass ein
impfstoff vielleicht wenn man viel glück
hat bis zum jahresende vorhanden ist
dass diese aber dann in der breite der
gesellschaft auch wirklich ankommt mit
anderen worten dass es sicherheit vor
diesem corona virus gibt das könnte noch
monate dauern möglicherweise bis mitte
nächsten jahres und joe biden hat eben
den plan vorgelegt dass stattdessen dann
andere maßnahmen zunächst einmal greifen
müssen zum beispiel maske tragen zum
beispiel abstand halten da wo es
notwendig ist auch wieder lockt downs
der präsident bestreitet das er hat in
diesem punkt glaube ich schlecht
ausgesehen weil joe biden es geschafft
hat sehr klar und deutlich zu machen
dass diesen präsidenten jedenfalls aus
seiner sicht nicht allzu viel an den
menschen draußen im land liegt sondern
in erster linie an der wirtschaft und er
hat sich direkt joe biden hat sich
direkt an die menschen gewendet er hat
direkt in die kamera geschaut sie
einzeln angesprochen und ich glaube
damit hat er ein paar punkte gemacht
denn der präsident hatte außer einem
impfstoff dem nicht viel
entgegenzusetzen
so jetzt hab ich hier gerade ein kleine
fehler gemacht ist auch noch früh
morgens bei uns wir wollten eigentlich
nämlich mal kurz zusammenfassen wie die
einzelnen themen abgelaufen sind das hat
jutta sonder wald für uns getan
so und jetzt hängt der beitrag schade
also das ist ja noch ein bisschen früh
auch unser review system muss noch mal
kurz aufwachen
ich frage nein wir machen erstmal weiter
mit dem nächsten großen themen punkt
rassismus also corona hatten wir gerade
schon da hat unser kurs matthäus und
gemeint sei donald trump nicht gut aus
dass weitere große brisante thema im
land ist rassismus spätestens nach dem
tod von torchlight dem afroamerikaner
durch die hände von polizeibeamten ist
da ja auf den straßen einiges los die
black light meter bewegung ist zurück
protestiert seit monaten und die frage
im land ist ja immer wie rassistisch
sind die usa überhaupt noch oder sind
sie rassistisch wie haben sich die
beiden da aufgestellt
der präsident sagte eben es gebe keinen
rassismus im land es sei nicht so wie
die andere seite aus seiner sich die
black lips meter und die protestbewegung
behauptet während joe biden ganz klar
sagt es gibt so etwas wie rassismus in
den usa ist in teilen auch systemisch
und deswegen will er wenn er denn
präsident würde eine art kommission
einen runden tisch zusammenrufen um
diese frage anzugehen wie man rassismus
in den usa bekämpfen kann den
tatsächlich viele afroamerikaner viele
schwarze viele hispanics auch in ihrem
alltag erleben
der präsident hat im grunde genommen so
getan als gäbe es das nicht er hat
andere themen dann aufgerufen hat
versucht abzulenken und hat vor allen
dingen behauptet dass es zu beiden und
den demokraten in erster linie darum
geht die polizei regelrecht abzuschaffen
das sei mit dem wort die funding the
police gemeint joe biden dagegen hat
sehr klar gemacht und zwar sehr
eindeutig da geht es gar nicht darum es
geht darum die polizei zu reformieren
ihr möglicherweise sogar mehr mittel zu
geben in form von personal wie
psychologen die beispielsweise bei
einsätzen mitfahren können weil so
mancher streit zudem die polizei gerufen
wird gar nicht unbedingt durch
polizisten und am ende den
schrecklichsten form mit der waffe
gelöst werden kann sondern am ehesten
vielleicht durch sozialarbeiter und
psychologen dass er hat ganz klar gesagt
es geht ihm nicht darum die polizei
abzuschaffen sondern
sie zu reformieren und dafür sorge zu
tragen dass die sogenannten faulen äpfel
also die polizisten die ihre kompetenzen
überschreiten die rassistisch sind die
müssten aus der polizei ausgesondert
werden so unterschätzt da können wir uns
zumindest mal 12 o töne aus der debatte
anhören das ist ein präsident der alles
benutzt hat um rassistischen hass und
rassistische spaltung zu erzeugen
sind sie bereit heute abend white
supremacy und militante gruppen zu
verurteilen sie sollen zurücktreten und
bereitstehen aber ich sage euch was
jemand muss etwas gegen antifa und die
linken unternehmen das ist kein problem
der rechten das ist ein problem der
linken el mati wissen gibt es da
überhaupt irgend eine annäherung
zwischen den beiden oder ist das einfach
wirklich ein tiefer graben der da auch
das land läuft ist nicht nur tiefer
graben sondern obendrein auch ein
fatales signal so jedenfalls sehen es
alle beobachter die ich heute abend so
ein bisschen verfolgen konnte er hat ja
mit den worten die er gesprochen hat die
braut boys gemeint das sind weiße
rassisten weiße rechtsextremisten die
hat er auch direkt angesprochen als
braut boys und den hat er gesagt haltet
euch zurück aber haltet euch bereit und
das wird jetzt schon von dieser
rechtsextremistischen gruppe als eine
art slogan benutzt um klar zu sagen
jawohl herr präsident wenn sie uns
brauchen stehen wir parat als er hat im
grunde genommen die rechtsextremisten
wieder befeuert statt sich klar von
ihrer gewalt zu distanzieren und
grundsätzlich jede form von gewalt
abzulehnen joe biden auf der anderen
seite hat genau das getan er hat gesagt
dass auch auf der seite der linken
natürlich gewalttäter sind aber eher
distanziert sich von dieser gewalt er
ist der meinung jeder der da gewalt
ausübt wo es daneben auch die härte des
gesetzes zu spüren bekommen
sodann gibt es außerdem das große thema
klima donald trump ist ja aus dem
pariser klimaabkommen ausgeschiedene
matthée wissen gibt es jetzt anzeichen
dass das sich ändern könnte wenn joe
biden
eventuell präsident werden würde wie ist
da die debatte zwischen den beiden beim
thema klima gelaufen also joe biden hat
ganz klar gesagt er will wieder den
paris account zustimmen er will wieder
eintreten und sich an die vereinbarungen
halten er will stück für stück das land
umbauen auf erneuerbare energien
allerdings nicht in einem kurzen
zeitplan innerhalb weniger jahre sondern
ein langfristiger plan er hat sich da an
einer stelle versprochen hat an einer
stelle einmal gesagt er würde den new
green deal unterstützen das ist ein plan
den vor allen dingen die linken flügel
der linke flügel in seiner eigenen
partei propagiert aber joe biden selber
lehnt den ab er sieht im grunde
maßnahmen vor die zunächst mal einen mix
aus verschiedenen energien vorsehen auch
erneuerbare energien
der präsident hat sich diesen fehler von
joe biden natürlich gleich zu nutze
gemacht gesagt seht ihr der unterstützt
ja wohl diesen green new deal er hat
einen art schreckgespenst hervorgerufen
oder ein ein szenario an die wand gemalt
dass die amerikanische wirtschaft massiv
leiden würden wenn man eben diese
umweltmaßnahmen alle umsetzen würde
er sagt der präsident sagt jawohl es
gibt wahrscheinlich so etwas wie
klimawandel war interessant zu hören hat
er so deutlich glaube ich noch nie
gesagt auch wenn es nicht ebenso klar
und eindeutig war wie arbeiten das getan
hat und er hat gesagt dass ein paar
maßnahmen die dafür sorgen dass man
saubere luft und sauberes wasser hat
absolut in ordnung ist sind aber er will
auf keinen fall
umfangreiche maßnahmen die aus seiner
sicht der amerikanischen wirtschaft
massiv schaden könnten
ich geh mal ein bisschen in die
kommentare ein erstmal muss ich euch
dazu auffordern doch möglichst moderat
zu bleiben
diese voll versuchen diese debatte nicht
nach zuspiel in unseren kommentaren aber
eine frage die hier einige umtreibt ist
was ist eigentlich mit dem alter ja
jetzt ja stina 143 schreibt auf youtube
und das ist auch andere auf facebook
schreiben sondern haben die amis keine
jüngeren kandidaten amerika amerika wird
vom altersheim aus regiert ist das
tatsächlich so gibt es da niemanden der
da hätte irgendwie mal als junger
frischer mensch antreten können gegen
einen doch auch mit
weil über 70 jährigen us präsidenten es
gab ja einige die demokraten hatten hier
über 20 bewerber und da waren auch
einige sehr junge leute dabei zb als
bürgermeister aus indiana beat boutique
der von vielen auch gehandelt wurde als
möglicher neuer star in der
demokratischen partei
aber am ende haben die wähler in diesem
fall die vor wähler der demokratischen
partei entschieden und sich ganz klar
hinter dem 77-jährigen joe biden
versammelt und zwar vor allen dingen
deshalb weil glaube ich eher so eine art
mischung aus viel erfahrung aber eben
auch anstand würde repräsentiert viele
leute sehe sich ein stück weit nach ruhe
nach diesen vier jahren donald trump am
ende ist es ebenso beiden geworden aber
tatsächlich teil sicherlich viele
wahrscheinliche wähler der demokraten
das gefühl von justina eigentlich müsste
es doch jetzt mal ein paar jüngere geben
die ran müssen die alten haben sich ja
auch vorhin ein wirkliches unwirklich
unwürdiges spektakel geliefert 74 und 77
jahre sind sie alt da kann man dann nur
auf die vize-präsidentin verweisen mike
bands auf der einen seite aber vor allen
dingen natürlich kabel harris auf der
anderen seite die ich glaube weiß dass
sie möglicherweise eben parat stehen
muss für den fall dass joe biden wenn
der präsident wird ihm irgendwann einmal
etwas zustoßen könnte und dann hätten
wir auf einmal eine schwarze junge frau
als us-präsidentin dass wir auch mal ein
novum
wie gehen wir weiter in den themen die
dort heute abend oder heute abend bei
ihr bei euch bei uns heute morgen oder
heute nacht besprochen wurden die
steuern waren ein großes thema diese
steuererklärungen von donald trump die
sind ja schon im wahlkampf 2016 immer
wieder besprochen wurden donald trump
hat sich hartnäckig geweigert die
herauszugeben jetzt hat die new york
times am montag einen artikel publiziert
in dem sie davon schreibt er hätte zwei
jahre lang 750 dollar bezahlt und andere
jahre überhaupt gar nichts zu bieten hat
daraufhin seine steuererklärung
veröffentlicht und hat den nach 2009 10
fast 300.000 dollar bezahlt und auch da
gab es natürlich einen heftigen
schlagabtausch wir hören mal ganz kurz
ein
ist es wahr dass die zeitweise
750 dollar steuern gezahlt haben im jahr
ich habe millionen dollar steuern
gezahlt
ich habe 38 millionen dollar steuern
gezahlt in einem jahr in einem anderen
27 millionen
dann zeigen sie uns die steuererklärung
sie werden sie bekommen wenn sie fertig
ist so das ist natürlich sehr spannend
da gibt es die informationen der new
york times 750 dollar gegen die aussagen
von us-präsident trump die halt ein
bisschen höher sind und der zeigt man
kann sie sehen sobald sie fertig sind
wie passt das ganze zusammen da steht
man ja so ein bisschen davor im große
fragezeichen im kopf oder ja solange er
seine steuererklärung nicht
veröffentlicht kann man natürlich nicht
wissen wer hier die wahrheit spricht die
new york times sagt ganz klar und
eindeutig das sind die originaldokumente
die steuererklärung früherer jahre da
stehen diese 750 dollar drin weil er so
viele verluste geltend gemacht hat das
ist nicht illegal insofern hat die
beiden sicher nicht darauf eingelassen
zu sagen da ist etwas finsteres
illegales passiert aber hat gesagt das
zeigt dass das steuersystem in amerika
extrem ungerecht ist dass donald trump
durch seine steuersenkung in den
vergangenen jahren sogar noch ein stück
weit ungerechter gemacht hat weil vor
allen dingen die reichen davon
profitieren und weil einige
schlupflöcher drin sind die es eben
möglich machen dass man so viele
verluste daneben gegen rechnen kann und
er hat dann gleich gesagt das will er
ändern wenn er präsident wird und in den
nächsten vier jahren die steuern erhöhen
wird und zwar vor allen dingen für die
menschen die über 400.000 dollar im jahr
verdienen also ich sag mal für den denen
es besser geht in amerika es war eine
sehr spannende debatte und an dieser
stelle hat man tatsächlich mal
inhaltliche unterschiede zwischen den
beiden kandidaten sehr deutlich gesehen
und das muss mal kurz in die kommentare
gehen hier gibt es einen kommentar
direkt an mich gerichtet von günter
rhodius auf facebook der schreibt wird
dieser texte ablesen moderator in
anführungszeichen im studio und jetzt
vorschreiben wie wir zu kommentieren
haben also erst mal lese ich keine texte
ab hier stehen nur fragen auf meinem
zettel das ist das eine und das andere
ich möchte niemandem vorschreiben wie
ihr diskutiert wird aber ich möchte doch
wirklich darum bitten dass die
zivilisiert sachlich bleiben und nicht
populistisch und polemisch weil das
bringt niemanden weiter
und wir sind hier vor allem daran
interessiert eure einschätzungen zu
hören und eure fragen die dann
vielleicht unser us korrespondent
beantworten kann so aber schöne grüße an
herrn roos es gibt noch ein weiteres
thema quasi dieses steuerthema ist ja so
ein bisschen die achillesferse von
donald trump gewesen
auf der anderen seite hat sein
herausforderer joe biden auch eine
kleine achillesferse nämlich seinen sohn
dann gibt es immer wieder vorwürfe
betreffend seiner geschäfte in den usa
in den oder ukraine und mit china hunter
beiden heißt der junge mann und auch da
haben wir mal ganz kurz aus der debatte
ein
da konnte man ja fast gar nichts mehr
hören was dort gesagt wurde also es gibt
die vorwürfe
das handarbeiten aus der us-armee
entlassen wurde das eher unlautere
geschäfte macht mit der ukraine was ist
an diesen vorwürfen dran was kann man
davon tatsächlich belegen also ganz
wichtig erst mal vorweg das war einer
der tiefpunkte dieser debatte weil die
beiden tatsächlich schon angegriffen
worden ist in bezug auf seinen anderen
sohn handarbeiten im früheren verlauf
der debatte da war das schon ein großes
thema da hat joe biden ganz klar gesagt
das stimmt nicht das ist falsch das ist
eine lüge und alles was wir bisher
wissen dann ermittlungen was bisher
öffentlich vorliegt was übrigens auch
durch
mitarbeiter der us-regierung von donald
trump mittlerweile teilweise bestätigt
worden ist auch durch ehemalige
mitarbeiter
es gibt da keinen beweis dafür dass
handarbeiten unter der vize
präsidentschaft schon von joe biden
tatsächlich massiv profitiert habe oder
in schmutzige geschäfte verwickelt
worden ist es ist sicherlich so dass es
nicht besonders gut aussieht wenn der
sohn eines vize-präsidenten einen
lukrativen deal im ausland bekommt wenn
man aber darüber redet müsste man da
gleich mal über ivanka trump und auch
donald trump junior reden die ebenfalls
entsprechende deals haben ich glaube
hier ist das entscheidende dass an
dieser stelle der präsidentin noch mal
die attacke geritten hat und das war die
stelle an der joe biden über seinen
anderen sohn beau biden sprach einer der
tatsächlich im irak verdienste erworben
hat der dann später eben gestorben ist
an einer schweren krankheit und in dem
moment kommt der präsident wieder auf
handarbeiten zu sprechen und
handarbeiten ist nicht unehrenhaft aus
der armee entlassen worden
das war eine klare lüge des präsidenten
handarbeiten hat drogenprobleme gehabt
das hat der vizepräsident joe biden
daneben auch gleich im anflug anschluss
an diese szene die wir gerade gehört
haben gesagt und hat gesagt viele im
land haben ja auch drogenprobleme und
jeder kann nachvollziehen das ist dann
schwierig ist sein leben wieder auf die
reihe zu bekommen
also ich glaube auch hier hat der
präsident eigentlich er sich selbst
geschadet weil das ein ich sag mal ein
tiefschlag war der sicherlich bei
manchen zu schauen und es waren
vermutlich etwa 100 millionen zuschauer
in den usa nicht wirklich gut angekommen
ist
sophie sprechen gerade in unseren
korrespondenten partie wissen in den usa
über die präsidentschafts debatte
zwischen joe biden und us-präsident
standesamt wir haben schon gesprochen
über das thema corona über das thema
steuern über das thema rassismus und
über das thema klima ist alles in dieser
debatte heute nacht vorgekommen und
jetzt können wir euch auch einmal kurz
dass die zusammenfassung von meiner
kollegin jutta sonder weit vor spielen
die soeben kleinen schluck auf hatte
beim ersten fernsehduell zwischen
präsident trump und seinem
demokratischen herausforderer joe biden
in cleveland ohio gibt es diesmal keinen
handshake und kaum publikum
der grund corona chance umgang mit der
pandemie und die wirtschaftlichen folgen
eines von sechs großen themen in diesen
90 minuten
er wusste schon seit februar wie schlimm
diese krise ist dass es eine tödliche
krankheit ist sie sollten aus ihrem
bunker herauskommen und ihren golfplatz
verlassen und lieber mal im weißen haus
mit demokraten und republikanern einen
plan entwickeln wie man leben retten
kann samt weist jegliche kritik am
umgang mit der pandemie zurück im
gegenteil wir sind nur wenige wochen von
einem impfstoff entfernt wir behandeln
die erkrankten es sterben weniger
menschen wir haben einen tollen job
gemacht
die beiden kandidaten liefern sich einen
heftigen schlagabtausch fallen sich
immer wieder ins wort und beleidigen
einander
man kommt ja kaum zu wort bei diesem
clown an die jetzt nichts schlaues du
hast in 47 jahren nichts erreicht trump
scheint in der defensive und wie der
wähler bei einer wahlniederlage keinen
friedlichen machtübergang zu sichern
beiden dagegen kann punkten indem er das
fernsehpublikum öfters direkt anspricht
eher wenig darüber sprechen was ihr
braucht das amerikanische volk es geht
um euch herausforderer joe biden scheint
bei diesem ersten tv duell etwas besser
abgeschnitten zu haben als präsident
jump so das ergebnis einer ersten
blitzumfrage so wir gucken um meine
kommentare immer hier gibt es einiges
einmal natürlich das ist üblich bei
gerade auch so einem polarisierenden
thema trump fans und gegner liefern sich
erhitzt schlagabtausch
damals war die bitte leute bleibt
sachlich ich hatte hier aber auch so mal
ein paar fragen die ich ganz interessant
fand da muss ich jetzt einmal hier durch
die kommentare auf youtube scrollen hier
zum beispiel legt seine behauptungen von
etienne baptist gemessen an ökonomischen
faktoren konnte kein anderer präsident
kommt das wasser
reichen unter anderem die geringste
armut seit 1959
das würde ich dann doch gerne mal
unseren us dokumenten der materie sind
tragen ist das so korrekt nein das ist
falsch und das kann man sehr klar
nachweisen die der graben zwischen arm
und reich hat sich noch weiter
vergrößert in der amtszeit von donald
trump der muss man aber sagen hat sich
auch schon in den amtszeiten
vorhergehender präsidenten demokraten
wie republikaner deutlich vergrößert
also ich nenne da mal ein beispiel wenn
man auf das jahr 19 2 1020 schaut dann
sagen im jahr 2020 menschen die gefragt
werden ob es ihnen besser geht als ihren
eltern eigentlich nur noch 50 prozent
dass es ihnen besser geht als ihren
eltern im jahr 1980 also 40 jahre vorher
oder das gleiche gibt es als umfrage
auch aus früheren jahren da hat man 1980
gefragt wie viele von ihnen geht es
besser als ihren eltern im jahr 1940 und
dabei haben 90 prozent damals gesagt es
geht ihnen besser
wir sehen dass das reale einkommen bei
geringverdienern in den letzten jahren
in den letzten 20 jahren nur um ganz
wenige prozentpunkte gestiegen ist
während bei reichen es um 400 prozent
und damit meine ich wirklich die
superreichen in den usa um 400 prozent
gestiegen ist das einkommen also es ist
einfach nicht richtig zu behaupten dass
das die geringste armut ist und auch was
die arbeitslosenzahlen angeht da stimmt
ist zwar dass der präsident bis zur
corona krise wohlgemerkt vorzuweisen hat
die geringste arbeitslosenrate seit über
50 jahren
gleichzeitig hat er aber auch behauptet
er habe in den letzten jahren den ersten
jahren seiner amtszeit deutlich mehr
arbeitsplätze geschaffen als jeder
amerikanische präsident zuvor das ist
auch falsch denn barack obama hat in den
letzten drei jahren seiner amtszeit
deutlich mehr arbeitsplätze geschaffen
als donald trump in den ersten drei
jahren seiner amtszeit so und dann kam
die korona krise und die hat im grünen
meer um alles zerstört das heißt wenn
man das in die rechnung mit einbezieht
dann steht amerika so schön
echt da wie seit jahrzehnten nicht mehr
ökonomisch gesehen und die große frage
wie schnell kommt man wirtschaftlich
wieder auf die füße dafür braucht man
einen plan und der ist jedenfalls bei
donald trump heute abend nicht sichtbar
gewesen
dann geht sie in den kommentaren um die
außenpolitik die wir heute oder heute
nacht in der debatte ja kein thema das
wird wahrscheinlich noch nachgeholt aber
hier gibt es kommentare wie von
gitarristen der schreibt vier jahre
frieden unter präsident stammzellen für
euch gar nichts sind hier jahre frieden
für euch nichts wert dass es euch kein
wort wäert dir dein kommentar ist gerade
vor vier jahre in denen keiner durch
amerikanische waffen gestorben ist sind
ja so schlecht und auch ähnlich gibt es
einen kommentar habe ich gelesen da geht
in die richtung
er hat nicht wieder erreicht aber auch
nicht wie kaputt gemacht was sagen sie
denn dazu
oder was hast du dazu immer wieder
sprechen wir mal gerne ein paar worte
dazu also ist überhaupt keine frage dass
vier jahre frieden erstmal ein verdienst
sind es ist auch überhaupt keine frage
dass einige von den vermeintlichen
friedens friedens deals die
abgeschlossen hat ich sage bewusst
vermeintlich und erkläre das gleiche
auch zunächst mal ein fortschritt sind
also der vertrag zwischen nur die
vereinbarungen zwischen israel und
mehreren arabischen ländern
ich glaube da kann man sagen das ist ein
großer fortschritt dass da endlich
wieder geredet wird und dass man
überlegt wie man die beziehungen wieder
verbessert zwischen der arabischen welt
und israel
jetzt kommt das aber aber es ist aber
auf youtube 1900 fortschritte immerhin
ein anfang aber in bezug auf die anderen
dinge beispielsweise nordkorea wo er
sich auf die fahnen geschrieben hat
diesen diktator in nordkorea zu zähmen
und ihn an den verhandlungstisch zu
bringen stattdessen hat der diktator in
nordkorea hat die zeit genutzt um seine
waffenarsenale weiter auszubauen und hat
sich nicht beeindrucken lassen wirklich
von den avancen von donald trump also es
ist eine gemischte außenpolitische
bilanz mit gutem und mit schlechtem und
ich will noch eins als gutes hinzufügen
er ist aus dem mittelstrecken vertrag
ihren vertrag ausgestiegen da gibt es
sogar einigkeit bei der nato dass das
zunächst mal eine gute idee ist weil
schlicht und ergreifend russland sich
nicht mehr an diesen vertrag erhalten
hat und es vor allen dingen darum geht
dass auch künftig china irgendwie
einbezogen wird den solche regelungen
also es ist nicht alles schlecht bei
dodge ram aber das außenpolitische thema
das kommt eben vielleicht erst bei der
nächsten debatte so jetzt vielleicht
gerade zu hören wie ich mit einer regie
reden wollte sind gucken natürlich immer
auf die zahlen die viele menschen sind
noch live und dann habe ich gerade mal
einfach bei youtube kuckuck wir sind bei
stabil 2000 zuschauern
von daher scheint da noch interesse zu
sein dann können wir noch mal kurz
weiter reden über die briefwahl elmar
das ist ja auch ein großes thema donald
trump feiert die ganze zeit in richtung
des wahlergebnisses zweifelt die
briefwahl an sagt das wäre alles eine
einladung zum wahlbetrug und dann kommt
auch immer wieder die rede
auf diese wahlzettel die in einem fluss
gefunden wurden ich glaube mein stück
waren ist und das sollte auch sein name
gestanden haben wie ist da heute darüber
diskutiert wurden
ja dort wirtschaft hat das beispiel
natürlich auch wieder genannt ohne zu
sagen das ist nur nur in
anführungszeichen neuen stimmzettel
waren das ist natürlich nicht gut wenn
so etwas passiert aber von
flächendeckendem betrug und
wahlfälschung zu sprechen das entbehrt
jedenfalls derzeit noch jeder
empirischen grundlage und das sagen
nicht nur seine gegner seine politischen
gegner sondern das sagen sogar seine
eigenen sicherheitsbehörden allen voran
auch das fbi
also es gibt sehr viele bundesstaaten
oder eine reihe von bundesstaaten in
denen in der vergangenheit auch schon
per briefwahl gewählt worden ist da gab
es keine größeren wahlfälschung sphäre
und jetzt werden natürlich viel mehr
menschen wählen und ich glaube der
entscheidende punkt ist der streit darum
soll jemand einen stimmzettel erst mal
anfordern müssen so wie das in
deutschland ist da bekommt man ja eine
wahlbenachrichtigung und dann kann man
den stimmzettel anfordern und dann
wählen oder kriegt man schon gleich den
stimmzettel frei haus nach hause
geschickt und kann dann wählen da
schlummert angeblich eben ein großes
riesig
für betrug das machen aber gar nicht
alle bundesstaaten sondern nur ein teil
der bundesstaaten macht das so und noch
mal es gibt bisher keinen beleg dafür
dass dann wirklich größere wahlfälschung
zu erwarten ist fest steht dass wir
wegen der hohen briefwahlbeteiligung am
wahlabend wahrscheinlich das ergebnis
noch nicht kennen werden sondern das ist
vielleicht drei vier tage länger dauert
möglicherweise dauert es noch länger
und das wäre dann die gelegenheit und
deswegen war die frage des moderators an
die beiden auch so wichtig ob sie bereit
sind ein wahl also abzuwarten bis zu dem
punkt wo das wahlergebnis zertifiziert
ist also das amtliche endergebnis
vorliegt bevor sie vor die kameras
springen und dann sieg oder niederlage
in die kameras benennen und joe biden
hat sich da sehr klar festgelegt wenn
ich gewinne werde ich das akzeptieren
wenn ich verliere werde ich das
akzeptieren
donald trump hat eben das nicht gemacht
und das führt natürlich im grunde um die
ängste und die sorgen dass er sich
weigern könnte das amt zu verlassen wenn
der wahlausgang nicht eindeutig und zwar
sehr schnell am wahlabend schon gelegt
war ist und was würde dann passieren
müsste man dann tatsächlich auch wenn es
irgendwann ein gerichtsurteil gibt ihnen
aus dem weißen haus tragen oder bis das
verfahren dann den usa es gibt eine
ganze reihe von szenarien also zunächst
einmal würde sicherlich ist so sein dass
der präsident einfach sieg erklärt wenn
er bei den präsenz stimmen also denen
die wirkliche wahllokal abgegeben worden
sind vorne liegt das wäre vorstellbar da
hat er mehrfach schon hinweise darauf
gegeben dass er das tun könnte beide
seiten würden wahrscheinlich ihre
anhänger mobil machen dass die
demonstrieren auf der straße beide
seiten würden möglicherweise dann vor
gericht ziehen das kann bis zum obersten
gerichtshof laufen
und da gibt es die unterschiedlichen
szenarien entweder entscheidet
vielleicht nachher wie im jahr 2000 der
oberste gerichtshof darüber was denn
jetzt eigentlich gilt und wenn es bis
zum 20
januar noch nicht zu einer klaren lösung
gekommen ist auch das heißt in der
geschichte schon mal gegeben dann gibt
es verschiedene regelungen die
wichtigste besagte in der amerikanischen
verfassung und
12 uhr mittags am 20 januar erlischt die
amtszeit von donald trump und wenn dann
nicht klar ist wer der nachfolger ist
dann wird eben ein nachfolger aus den
reihen des amerikanischen kongresses
bestimmt entweder ist es dann die mehr
als führerin im repräsentantenhaus nancy
pelosi oder das hängt auch davon ab ob
die kongresswahlen sauber ablaufen
können jetzt im november ist auch
vorstellbar dass aus dem senat heraus
eine person dann bestimmt für die am 20
januar zum amerikanischen präsidenten
vereidigt wird übergangspräsidenten
wurde sodann kommen wir mal zum schluss
mir tut nämlich auch so ein bisschen ein
rechter arm den cancel zeit dann
entweder einen telefon ans ohr passen
muss weil wir da schwierigkeiten mit
deinem kopf beraten
schlussfrage wie immer wer hat jetzt
diese dvd 11 für sich entschieden was
sagen die umfragen oder auch eine frage
hier noch aus dem chat wer hat die
besseren berater trump oder beiden also
69 prozent der amerikaner sagen nach
einer blitzumfrage dass das eine ganz
schreckliche debatte war da sind sich
also sehr viele offenbar sehr einig und
viele sagen auch die deutliche mehrheit
sagt dass joe biden die nase vorn hatte
weil dort treffen sich offenbar
entschieden hat destruktiv zu sein von
vorne bis hinten und das sammelt ihm
nicht unbedingt pluspunkte es war
offenbar der versuch des ich sag mal
amtsinhabers der deutlich hinter joe
biden in den umfragen liegt irgend eine
situation entstehen zu lassen in der joe
biden so schlecht aussieht dass er
dramatisch an zustimmung verliert das
hat heute nicht gegeben bei diesem duell
deswegen würde ich mal behaupten wir
werden keine große bewegung nach oben
für donald trump in den umfragen sehen
für joe biden glaube ich kann man sagen
er hat wahrscheinlich seine seine zahlen
gefestigt aber wir sind ja noch nicht am
ende es kommen noch zwei weitere
debatten zwischen den beiden und dann
sind eben auch noch ein paar wochen in
denen die in amerika und in der welt
viel passieren kann dann vielen dank
aber ich möchte noch einen kommentar
tatsächlich kurz zeigen in deine
richtung
vielleicht geht immer auf meinem
bildschirm ganz kurz in der regie
da dies schreibt
respekt an den report hat er sich sehr
stunden am stück das handy ans ohr
halten kann
in diesem sinne vielen dank in die usa
und da kann ich jetzt sagen hoffentlich
bald gute nacht ich wünsche ich hier im
livestream einen guten morgen
vielen dank fürs zu sehen für eure
fragen und kommentare und bis zum
nächsten live stehen
wir sehen uns macht gut und tschüss
[Musik]